within seconds a person's life can
change forever or be extinguished
entirely Emil witnessed that for himself
on November the 13 2015 it's also when
he truly recognized how important it is
to help others michael walla walla walla
make John now when I see someone in the
street is having problems with their
bike for instance I'll stop and see
what's happening now I'll take the two
minutes soku oil on the evening of the
Paris attacks Emil was working at labahn
bia as usual suddenly he heard sounds
like firecrackers only louder when the
noise stopped Emil left the kitchen to
see what was happening
it was unimaginable a scene of sheer
horror there were pools of blood and
people with gunshot wounds all over the
world among the wounded was Pauline a
young woman Emile's age gives the
crystal more involved or she taken a
bullet in her upper arm and another in
the leg i sat down next to her and
thought about what I should do that's
always offer you know Wally because will
emil remained calm he wrapped a towel
around Pauline's wounded shoulder which
was bleeding heavily and he kept talking
to her while they were waiting for help
to arrive someone suddenly shouted that
the terrorist was coming back in his
fear Emil ran upstairs to get away and
left Pauline downstairs still she
managed to follow him though she could
barely stand up here living with you for
more on she came towards me and said
please don't leave me alone please stay
with me and I felt really ashamed for
leaving all the proof I Melissa little
as well as give them all at that moment
Emil realized what it means to be there
for someone else and he knew that only
one thing counted that night making sure
that Pauline survived today he's
convinced that helping Pauline also
helped him to come to grips with the
terrorist attack it enabled him to
maintain some semblance of control and
kept him from being traumatized by the
horrible scenes around him
but most victims of terror attacks react
differently they feel completely
helpless in the situation like my teen
be saw 20 years ago she was sitting in a
commuter train on her way to work when a
bomb exploded in the neighboring
carriage she suffered both physical
injuries and severe psychological trauma
yet she was determined to resume living
a normal life as quickly as possible in
medieval battles I hide my doctor wanted
to write me off sick but I said if I
didn't start riding the train to work
i'll never get on one again he jumped on
but to this day I jumped whenever I hear
a sound that even vaguely resembles an
explosion and it'll likely be that way
for the rest of my life popular is get a
phone visual Emil is not traumatized by
what he experienced but in the weeks
after the attack he felt compelled to
find out what had happened to Pauline
when the world is always great to find
her alive and in a more stable condition
the doctors were able to save Pauline's
arm but she isn't prepared to talk about
her experiences on camera still she and
Emil have felt a connection to one
another ever since those terrible hours
when they both fought to save her life
you